A formal explanation of Virtualization
is given in an old paper by Povek and
Goldberg from 1974.
There is a link to that paper
in the instructor's notes.
We'll go through the ideas that
are presented in that paper and
we will explain how to
define Virtualization.
The definition states that a virtual
machine is taken to be an efficient
isolated duplicate of the real machine.
Virtualization is enabled through
a virtual machine monitor, or VMM.
This is the layer that enables
virtual machines to exist.
As a piece of software,
the virtual machine monitor has
three essential characteristics.
The virtual machine monitor
provides an environment for
programs that's essentially
identical with the original machine.
As I said the capacity may differ,
however it would be the same kind of CPU
that the virtual machine thinks it has.
The same types of devices, etc.
What this means is that as the, one of
the goals of the virtual machine monitor
is that it must provide some fidelity
that the representation of the hardware
that's visible to the, in the virtual
machine matches the hardware that's
available on the physical platform.
Second, programs that run in
this environment show at worst
only minor decrease in speed.
Now, clearly we have a situation
where the operating system and
its processes in the virtual
machine are given only
two CPUs as opposed to the four that
are available on the physical machine.
This won't execute exactly at the same
level, it wouldn't be able to complete
the programs as fast as
if they were in natively.
However the goal of the virtual machine
monitor is that if the virtual machine
were given the exact amount of
resources as the physical machine,
then the operating system, and
the processes, would be able
to perform at the same speeds.
So another goal of the virtual machine
monitor, is to deliver performance
to the VMs that's as close to
the need of performance as possible.
And last, the VMM is in complete
control of the system resources.
This means that the virtual machine
monitor has full control to make
decisions, who accesses which
resources and when, and
it can be relied upon to ensure
safety and isolation among the VMs.
This doesn't mean that every single
hardware access has to be inspected
by the VMM layer.
Instead, what this means is that
the virtual machine monitor determines
if a particular VM is to be
given direct hardware access.
And also that, once those decisions
are put in place, a virtual machine can
not just change those policies, and
potentially hurt other collocated VMs.
So one of the goals for
the virtual machine monitor is
that it has to provide for
safety and isolation guarantees.